[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to research and focus
again I'm Gretchen who's Inga and right
now we're talking to two researchers who
are working on a revolutionary storage
solution for computer storage in the
zettabyte era we have an tro stryn who's
a principal researcher in the deputy lab
director at MSR in Cambridge England and
and Rumaki
Schatzi left t to you who is a postdoc
researcher in systems and networking
also at the cambridge lab welcome to
both of you thanks for joining us today
so you're both working on a really
interesting project called project
silica and it's in the research stage
right now but it'sit's just fascinating
what you're doing so ant in broad
strokes tell us what it is give us an
elevator pitch of project silica okay so
to project silica is really looking at
how do we build a new storage system for
the cloud era from this from the ground
up so rather than starting with existing
components like tape or hard disk drives
we're looking at a new type of storage
media glass and what's happened recently
is a breakthrough at the University of
Southampton was they discovered how to
write data into this glass and we have
been trying to both use that and develop
it further and then build an entire
storage system based upon upon that and
that's what project silica is trying to
do and Rumaki what's changed in the
magnitude of the data landscape that
we're dealing with today that would
prompt research on a completely new
storage medium if you will and one of
the limitations that we're facing in the
current technologies so the amount of
data that we need to preserve for a long
time because increase dramatically over
the last few years so we expect that
within the foreseeable future where we
expect the storage needs doing great
data bytes of data so we need a massive
storage system able to sustain all this
data and that's the target of these
projects so so what's what is the
current structure limitation that we
would need to go into a different media
so first of all none of the existing
storage technologies that are currently
deployed in the glass
in the data centers have been originally
designed for the cloud right so we need
something specifically designed for this
environment and cost is a critical
factor and also we need to be able to
sustain high performance right right so
the existing technologies think about it
if you when we are talking about called
data storage the alternative solutions
include hard disk drives and tapes both
provide low cost per gigabyte but if you
want to store is it about data you need
millions of hardest yeah 115 terabyte
days in order to store this data and the
cost is prohibitive and think about it
it's not only about storing the data you
need every five to ten years we need to
migrate the data to the next generation
medium in order to be able to store this
data to double over time so we need the
new storage solution you have to to make
these challenges interesting I mean
that's one of the great things about
glass is that once you've written the
data in the glass it will last for a
long time all right think millions of
years so if you think of these other
technologies once you've written to them
it you know every three years or ten
years for tape three years for hard disk
drives you have to copy it off and copy
it on to the next one
with this technology once you've done it
it just sits there that doesn't require
any power it doesn't require any special
environment in particular you just keep
the glass there and when you need to
read the data again you just you can
just bring it in and read it or you can
just access it and read it right so so
in that line I've heard words like
revolutionary transformational stunning
applied to this particular technology
how does it work so so we fire
femtosecond lasers into the glass and
you sort of fade effect we focus the
laser at a position in the glass and
when you fire the laser in you generate
a smooth structure which we call a voxel
and that's what you use to actually
encode the data inside the glass and
then once you've written
data you then also need to read the data
to better get the data back out so we
have with effectively developing systems
which allow us to read the data back out
from the glass and one of the things
that's very different about this is
there are many many layers you can think
of so if a piece of glass is having
multiple layers of data through it now
if you takes me like a traditional
optical disc used in a DVD or blu-ray
Atari system at the lyric that might
have four layers or eight layers these
can potentially have hundreds of layers
and so you need techniques that let you
be able to read the data from deep
within the glass and go to accurately
extract out the information that you've
stored in the glass and so you've
already kind of gone through there's a
research and say hey this works we're
getting we're getting close we can you
know almost every week we're improving
performance dramatically at the moment
we're at about 75 layers that we can
read which is a huge step forwards from
where we were which is around 20 layers
before Christmas so you know we're
making great progress and the technology
is ensuring rapidly from the stage where
it was sort of like a large room in
Southampton to the stage where we can
start to think what it might look like
as it goes into a data center
interesting so what challenges have you
faced in the research of this new
technology and how have you have you
resolved the challenges one of the main
challenges is how we can drive the
pretense city of this new storage medium
up so if you think about the technical
challenges the way some of the ways in
which we can increase the density is for
instance increase a number of layers or
we can reduce the spacing between these
nanostructures decided the glass however
both approaches result result in
increased noise and this complicates the
read out process so it's not actually
straightforward we are what you know
that we've made great progress within
the lab and but it's something that
you're still working on to try to yeah
and I think you could have took the hard
disk drive industry about 40 years from
the point when they first started to the
point where now where they kind of
reached the plateau what they can do an
areal density and I'm looking at other
techniques to improve performance and
you know we so we you're at the limit if
if you took a DVD size and a piece of
glass
Southampton believe you can get about
360 terabytes inside a piece of glass
but you know it will take us many many
years to get there and at the moment our
challenge is to get the first you know
to get it to a density where it's sort
of competitive with existing things once
we get beyond that point everything is
then a win after three so at this point
it's still at the phase where it's you
know this is still better the old
technologies are still better or yeah I
mean you know we're the point where
we're starting to catch up with where
they are and you know as we say every
every week or every month we're making a
great step forward so we expect very
soon
you know most most technology exists on
an s-curve and in a sense we're at the
start of this s-curve so we make a lot
of we make a you know at least we're at
the start of the bit where it's
beginning to grow so we're starting to
see the progress we put a lot of time
getting infrastructure understanding the
technology making it repeatable and now
we're beginning to really three at a
meet the other side is great yeah talk
about the design challenges I was
interested in some of the things you
were saying about how you have to
conceptualize a brand new technology for
storage so what's exciting in this
project is that we are building a
completely new storage system from the
ground up so we are not limited by form
factors similarly to the previous
storage technologies so we can explore a
relative safe alternative sizes for the
class major so everything is open and we
are following a data-driven design and
we are trying to understand what's the
optimal design in order to get a system
that can maximize the performance and
minimize the cost right so ant give us a
little bit of an overview of what you
called hot cool and cold data storage
needs we've talked about the context of
how and where we store things when we
need to access
and how and how does project silica
address that whole system yeah so you
know if you think the data that you're
accessing frequently you know if we
think of taking photographs the
photographs that you're taking today
you're probably looking at an accessing
frequently so that would be considered
sort of hot data data that act and then
as you access the data less frequently
so you know if you think of photographs
that you took a month ago you've perhaps
a k-- system but nowhere near as
frequently as the ones you took
yesterday and then of course the ones
you took five or six years ago you
probably never access and they're
they're cold so we started had hot data
which is used frequently warm data which
is sort of accessed fairly frequently
but not too frequently and then cold
data and you know the vast majority of
data that's stored is actually cold and
that's the kind of data that we're
trying to store in an service with
project silica and one of the challenges
is if you look at most storage
technologies as they reduce cost to in
order to store these technologies they
also increase access latency and one of
the advantages of really designing from
the ground up is that we can really say
well we have ideas of that exactly how
long people were willing to wait for
there for that cold data can we build a
system that can give us that kind of
access latency if you think it'll be
like tape you've got to spool the tape
you've got to get the tape there you've
got to find the right point you've got
to take it back out before you can use
it and so forth and so there's a lot of
latency in the system so this is one of
the challenges we're trying to address
to make it so it's even though it's cold
data accessed infrequently you don't
have to pay a really high penalty to
access it yeah and that brings up a
question that I'm curious about in terms
of you know accessing that data I want
to find a picture that I took five years
ago and it's been in my cold storage
system as it were this project silica
present any accessibility strategies for
me when I'm going where was that picture
that I took of my daughter when she was
at camp that year yeah we would call
that sort of better data that you would
store so we don't we don't provide any
services we have other services around
which will which will provide the
metadata you know you can have a machine
learning pipeline that looks at the
pictures as they go in and tags them
with words and
stores that in a system that you can
search and all we're really worried
about is how do you store the data and
how do you store it efficiently and at
low cost
for long-term storage forever so as soon
as you're part of the team at Microsoft
Research are there any other teams writ
large that you're dealing with as you
develop this new storage system yeah we
have a great collaboration with Azure
storage and we are learning from them
about how these can be deployed actually
in the data center and actually we also
given that we're following a data-driven
design the properties of the current
workload are really important to us
right yeah so they're also helping us
with this part great we're excited yeah
so I'm really interested in what this
looks like I have visions in my head of
all kinds of form factors as you
mentioned for what the glass looks like
do you have a piece of glass with you
that we could look at can you see the
little dots there you go so those are
the media written the voxels returning
the gloves
yeah using circle plays now seems to
each one of those dots that you can see
is actually a hundreds or thousands of
voxels so they're placed very close
together and then there's a set of them
that you can see on here so the dots
that I see there what is that and how
many layers are there so these
particular summary we have around 25
player no 25 layers
yeah it's an old assembly which happens
to correct with me and currently we are
able to write up to 75 layers I have
read them but yeah that's fascinating
so here's a video that shows how one of
our early prototype read heads reads
data from the piece of glass on the
right hand side you could see the the
piece of glass in there and you can see
those little little collections of
voxels that we just shown you in the
piece of glass here and you can see the
head moving over it on the left-hand
side you can see the picture of each
we call sector as you move across those
sets of voxels and then in a second it
will stop and it'll go down through the
glass and you'll see 20 layers of voxels
each one coming into focus going out
coming in going out coming in going out
beautiful so let's say you're wildly
successful project silica ramps up hits
that curve going up and it's it's
deployed widely what does what does the
future look like so I think it's really
exciting so at one level the number of
bytes that would be stored in glass will
be ginormous so if you think about it as
the technology that will do will store
most of the data because most the data
is cold so you know we would expect a
large amount to move on to it it also
has a great property that's very low
cost which means that you no longer need
to worry about the data that you're
storing in hand which is going to cost
you because the cost will be much much
lower than today's technologies and the
other thing is you know for many things
we actually worry about losing them and
you know if you think of sometimes films
or sometimes TV series were done early
you know years ago we've lost them
because they decayed the great thing
about this is this provides immediate
once you've written to it it doesn't
have any bit rot it doesn't decay you
can put it in water you can heat it you
can you can really abuse it and then
still effectively read it and so the
chances of actually losing something
that's written in it is really low and
of course you know if you think of
things like tablets and cavemen actually
chipping away on stone walls you know
this has proven to be a very effective
way of storing stuff and in fact that's
what we're doing we're changing it in a
way which is which is structurally
changing the glass and it will not decay
rot or anything else now a lot of people
think of medieval windows and think the
glass will yeah but but you know that
glass was very imporant
we use just pure quartz glass and so it
won't you know it doesn't it doesn't do
what a medieval window - that's good
news
interesting question from a data
generation point of view I take a lot of
pictures I don't care anymore I used to
care when it was on film cuz I had to
pay to get that done now my my phone is
full of pictures most of which I don't
even care about there's 20 of the same
thing
is there any effort in talking to people
about not generating so much data or is
that even you know you're just saying
hey they're going to so we're going to
make this cameras and you want to
capture its moment and it's very hard to
control that so the amount of data we
keep increasing and we need a way to
store this data at u-w that's great you
know I mean that's the point you can't
socially engineer the populace to not do
what they're doing with the technologies
that they have so you have to and you
know with things like you know
autonomous vehicles coming online I
think that it's you know cameras cameras
generate a huge amount of data and you
know I you know you know I mean it's
kind of interesting that I think in the
past you often don't know the value of
something if you you know 10 years ago
you might have taken four or five photos
of a whiteboard and then discarded all
of them except for one right you know
today using machine learning techniques
you can take multiple photos of the same
whiteboard and then use them to create a
higher fidelity photo
now of course 10 years ago you didn't
know that would be possible so those
fourth pictures that you had then had no
value so you bend them and that's one of
the things that you know we don't want
people to need to necessarily make
choices about which data they keep
because today they can perceive the
value it's cheap enough that you can
store all data and so if in the future
it becomes valuable because of
innovations in machine learning you can
exploit it you know having to worry that
you've actually lost some of the
information that was needed that's
fascinating it's that record now exploit
later you don't necessarily know what's
going to be valuable till later and then
you go I wish I had that I wish I didn't
throw it away yeah like those shoes I
kept from high school well I'm excited
to see where this work is going really
this is transformational research going
on in the Cambridge lab we're excited
that you guys came to share with us
today and andand Rumaki thank you so
much for joining us thank you for
joining us again for research and focus
and join us again for the neck
[Music]
[Applause]